hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm and today we are in
around eight of our coverage of the 2016
canada dis tournament whatever this
tournament does go on to face magnus
carlsen for the World Championship our
two competitors today are the two
Americans in the field fabiano caruana
playing the white pieces and nakamura
playing the black pieces with the World
Championship in the United States New
York later in November would be pretty
cool if an American did win but both
these players really need a victory
can't really have a draw or a loss
anywhere for the rest of the of the
tournament's or they're essentially outs
you know always depending on how their
opponents do but you can't have all your
opponent's loose they are going to beat
each other so winds are very essential
fabiano has tied every match so far so
he hasn't lost which is good but ties
only gets you so far he has three and a
half points through seven rounds
Nakamura has three points through seven
rounds he did get a very crucial win
last round if he could string two wins
together that would be very huge but
we'll go ahead and get started with
fabiano starting with Pawnee for Pawnee
59 f3 knight c6 Bishop b5 this is the
right Lopez we've been seeing more and
more this lately and for the last year
it seems like everyone is just playing
the same at Birdland offense Knight f6
you know later half of last year we
would see a lot of castle on the
kingside Knights a key for and then pawn
d for this is pretty common it seems
like in this tournament at least we've
been seeing a lot more of just pawn to
d3 which is what Caruana plays nakamo
responds with Bishop c5 Bishop takes
here on c6 after the pond recaptures the
night to d2 and this kind of came up in
round one with vision on but the night
can't take this pawn on e5 it does kind
of look like it's hanging out there but
after Knight takes on e5 then Queen down
here addy for it's just deadly threatens
mates right here on f 2 doesn't matter
how kind of Defense's whether it's Queen
d2 castle on the king's head either way
this nights going to fall Black is just
up way too much material controls the
center of the board White has no minor
pieces developed in the center this is
going to be a pretty easy game for black
to dominate so on board instead we see
night to d2
getting ready to come see for then have
double attackers on the e5 square so
this is kind of that the plan and then
once he has night see for this also
opens up the door for the dark squared
bishop on board casts on the Kings side
at queen e to rook e8 just having more
protection Knights c4s we talked about
opening up the door for the dark squared
bishop adding another attack Iran upon
me five so we see night come back here
d7 another defender on this pawn 'if
I've and then bishop d 2 and then Bishop
back here to d6 so Nakamura is kind of
overloading on this pond that need
necessarily all of those pieces but also
recognizing that the bishop on c5 isn't
really attacking anything to productive
right now now fabiano has two decisions
because he kind of played this Bishop
here to d2 he's done a good job of
getting all of his pieces developed he
can cast on the King side or the Queen
side after you kind of look at and say
in one specific match on you know random
opponent I would generally recommend
just castling on the King side I think
White has a very good game if you castle
on the King side he has a good pawn
structure going towards the late game
queen size a lot more aggressive though
it is we kind of solved from the last
match with nakamoto block you get to a
stage in the tournament's round eight is
definitely that stage where it's no
longer good enough to tie you know that
you need some wins and so while you see
cautious players early on we're kind of
in that stage where you're going to see
a lot more aggression and and so Fabiana
decides to go and castle on the
queenside anytime we have one side
castle on the Kings side the other side
cast on the queenside it's usually just
fireworks one side just those their
kitchen sink on one side the other
player tries to kind of hold up as much
as possible and then attack on the other
side Nakamura immediately starts to
attack on the queenside pawn b5 night
comes back here III pawn a five-night f5
so starting to attack on the King side
for fabiano that is Pawn a4 just trying
to extend he has a really good extension
of space over here on the queenside just
trying to push
as much of his pieces over here on the
queenside try to overload this white
king right here Bishop g5 forcing kind
of pawn f6 later on this does open up
the door for these light squares to have
an attack on the king nakamura should
look to kind of play king aj just to
have more secure Kings will kind of look
for that later in the game a bishop back
here to e3 it's probably much weaker to
just go ahead and take so Knight takes
on d6 all of a sudden pawn retakes you
know no longer has the double ponds then
Bishop e3 a three uh this proj is not as
good for white black has a really strong
attack right here so instead of giving
up that Knights decides to go ahead and
bring the bishop back here to e3 first
now night c5 pawn up here to geforce if
fabiano recognizing he needs to start to
attack a little bit himself over here on
the kingside a bishop e6 really putting
a lot of pressure on this pawn on a two
could have even if he wanted to push
forward pau nay three i think makes a
lot of sense you know he's kind of
looking at and says he doesn't
necessarily want just pawn be three
which is which is fine and so instead
decides to go and play Bishop here to e6
first now King to b1 b3 kind of loses to
pawn takes here and then it kind of just
blows up the protection from the pawns
now pawn to b4 just pushing a little
further pawn g5 now pawn b3 and things
get pretty interesting as far as how we
really defend this from White's
perspective and you could also try a
three but then kind of that be three I
think is a little easier for fabiana to
hold on to so knock more I think plays
it correctly and plays pawn b3 now rook
g1 just needs to make sure that he has
some sort of counter attack at all and
then pawn takes here on a 2k
over here a1 definitely would it be a
mistake I will can't take right here on
a 2 but to try to go over here see one
you can tell just going to get a queen
right here on a one so really only
option is king a one now the bishop
takes on f5 and you can see that that
bishop was protecting this pawn on a two
so keep that in mind now the King can
freely take if he wants to now after the
pawn takes on f5 now pawn to a three but
ponte a three makes it a lot more tricky
because if the King were to take on a
two it gets pretty crazy the pawn takes
on be too if the King takes then all of
a sudden Queen to be eight and black has
a mating threat in just a handful of
moves there's no way for white to really
stop this so although the bishop left
the e6 square nakamura definitely had a
plan to still kind of have a strong
attack and have this pawn on a to
defendant even though it's not
necessarily by a direct peace and we
kind of looked at what would happen if
the King takes your na too but also be a
mistake for the Pont take here on a
three because night to a4 is pretty
deadly it sets up for the bishop to take
here on a three also sets up for the
night to come to c3 forking both the
Queen and the rook here on d1 there's
not a lot of great squares the white can
really do to protect this and this kind
of blows up this Queen side of the board
office had McQueen came over here to be
aids get very involved into the game if
he needs to there's no protection
anymore in front of the Kings so knock
more recognizes this or fabiano
recognize this place pawn to be three
much better defense and then night to a
6 preparing for night b4 now I'm much
more the rather play king age 8 see what
my opponent does King h8 make sure that
there's no shenanigans later on with the
Queen controlling this light square
diagonal you know it gains a tempo after
I have to move my king at a check but
decides instead to play nine here to a 6
preparing for night down here to be for
now pawn to c3 fabiano
as you can imagine immediately
recognizes that and forth that attack
playing pawn c3 now Bishop back here f8
we do see Knight d2 and then after the
pawn takes rook captures here on g5 the
night comes back here to see five so
knock more used a couple moves and then
really do too much with his nights here
on c5 now the works going to come back
at g3 and then we have one of the more
questionable moves definitely in the
game so far and that is pawn to e4 now
we can't look at and say but you know
before this nakamura he's up upon so he
has seven pounds his opponent six
although his pawns are pretty terrible
he has two double bonds on the a file
which those you can almost count is 11
and a half maybe you have two ponds
double ponds on the C file that's not a
good pawn structure you have an isolated
pawn here on the e-file that's not that
great but he's up material and all of a
sudden pawn to e4 is just bad just gives
up material for no reason it essentially
gives up one of your powerful pieces
that you have an attack with for no
reason so after Pawnee for Bishop takes
on c5 Bishop recaptures in the night to
e4 white nail has a very aggressive
night in the sooner the board can't
really be attacked because of the stars
for a bishop can attack it and white
gain that material so all pretty
questionable move for nakamura not
really sure what he was going for Bishop
back here to d6 rook age 3 starting to
attack on the kingside bishop 'if I've
that's just going to be stopped by pawn
d for Bishop comes back here to f6 you
can start to see all the attacks that
knock him over is going for Fabio has
done a good job of kind of stopping them
and then over time just started to chip
away at summit material Nakamura no
longer has a lot of great material that
he would like to go ahead and attack his
opponents now rook to g1 fabiano starts
to kind of counter attack starts to put
a lot of pressure on the King side of
the board now rook ab8 met by King takes
on a tues just gobble
more material on board bishop age for it
is being protected by the Queen so the
root can't take it now that's going to
be a mistake but a rook up here to g4 so
essentially the bishop is going to have
to come back and retreat or just the
rooks going to take it in the Queen can
recapture onsted Nakamura decides for
one last hoorah Queen down here to d5
and then pawn to c4 this is going to
fourth the Queen to move and then this
Bishop is going to fall so in this
particular spot Nakamura is forced to
resign in essentially giving up any hope
that he goes on to win the tournament so
congratulations to fabiano caruana he
kind of catapults himself he's only half
a point off from the lead so for those
players out there hoping for someone
from the United States to win this term
if there is still hope we still have
kind of the leaders up top with levon
aronian and Santa gate karyakin they are
still up there with five points so
everyone playing well so far all the
other games were a drawl it's just you
can kind of keep up with all of the
action but hopefully you guys enjoyed
this match and I'll see you guys in the
next one for round nine